des stars donc qui s'engage auprès des
gilet jaune c'est un bref vrai sujet
nouvelle traite évidemment sur la partie
people donc la partie star c'est
difficile évidemment de passer en ce
moment à côté des gilets jaunes qui
monopolisent l'attention à tel point que
de nombreuses célébrités ont décidé de
soutenir le mouvement nombreuses pas
forcément en tant que ça et puis parfois
avec beaucoup de retard on essaie d'en
parler de comprendre pourquoi te poser
la question est-ce que c'est sincère ou
est-ce que c'est démago regarder pendant
plusieurs semaines électrocardiogramme
plat et puis tout à coup franck dubosc
que l'on suit le mouvement
on va tous ensemble faire quelque chose
on y réfléchit en attendant je vous n 7
à grand chose mais je suis là talonné
par le comédien arnaud ducret et moi je
vous soutiens alléger les gens se voient
là je suis avec vous que ce soit les dom
tom la lettre falloir le tous ensemble
la même galère on en a marre de casquer
comme des porcs ça y est les gilet jaune
qui attendait le soutien des peoples
sont entendus pierre perret je suis de
tout coeur avec vous brigitte bardot ou
encore jean marie bigard se font en
temps
c'est clair je soutiens de tout mon
coeur et gilet jaune pacifique
allez tous assemblés gars mais pourquoi
les personnalités on l a attendu aussi
longtemps avant d'afficher leur
sympathie celui qui le déclencheur de de
mon intervention chez vous aujourd'hui
c'est un monsieur qui avait 60 et
quelques années qui déjà eu une
augmentation de trois centimes dans
l'année pour ma retraite et mon fils est
aux restos du coeur le type semi
t'appeler s'est mise à pleurer
patrick sébastien donnerait même
l'impression d'être en campagne tient
les gens qui sont dans la rue les gilet
jaune c'est ma france c'est les
meilleurs ces gens-là qu'on méprise con
qu'on a qu'on met de côté de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique michel polnareff
exilé fiscal en son temps rappelez vous
il va de son petit conseil
j'espère que les violences ne vont pas
un peu abîmée une cause que je trouve
très sincère un engagement tardif comme
si les people avec une peur d'abîmer
leur carrière et vous qu'en pensez vous
sont ils sincères opportuniste
voilà donc les people qui s'engage ce
que c'est sincère ou est-ce que c'est
plutôt opportuniste jamais connu d'abord
la vie de rachel parce que rachel passé
très récent vous avez posté voilà un
tweet que j'aimerais lire maintenant
pour ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu vous avez
écrit je comprends voilà tout à fait la
colère des gilet jaune et du peuple
français nos politiciens sont bien loin
des réalités de ce que les français en
dur comment peuvent-ils les comprendre
je vivais dernièrement seul avec un smic
et un enfant élevé c'est pourquoi je
peux comprendre la détresse de bon
nombre de français
d'abord c'est bien de l'avoir dit de
l'avoir écrit mais de s'être engagé
comme ça c'est la première fois je crois
que vous engagez comme ça peut-être pour
un mouvement politique ou non bon à
l'avoir fait pourquoi l'avoir fait parce
que je vois et je comprends la colère de
des français je trouve normal en étant
une personnalité entre guillemets public
voilà deux d'apporter mon soutien vous
pensez que d'autres devraient le faire
que les personnalités plainte à chaque
chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il est
ce qu'il a envie et peut-être que ben
voilà ça y est ça ne les concerne pas où
ça ne touche pas directement donc après
chacun est libre et vous trouvez qu'ils
sont sincères vous vous l'étiez
visiblement de jeu pour vous demander si
vous dites opportunistes mais vous
trouvez que toutes les stars qu on dit
que souvent les hommes politiques font
de la récupération politique qu'est-ce
qui a pas des stars la récupération
entre guillemets de bonnes images en
disant c'est facile 80 % des gens sont
pour les gilet jaune dire je vous
comprends je vous aime assez populaire
si c'était opportuniste d'autres stars
l'aurait fait en fait je pense vous
n'êtes pas tort mais pas tant guillaume
guillaume pour vous c'est sincère ce que
font les stars évidemment parce que ce
sont des gens alors oui sont
certainement privilégier ce sont des
gens et donc ils soutiennent comme la
plupart des gens ils sont connectés
le seul qui me choque moi en me disant
c'est polnareff ça ça me choque un peu
vers los angeles dans sa sublime maison
il est parti alors je sais qu'il n'est
pas là à tort la jours avec avec tout
son argent et maintenant qu'il n'est
plus là était la web battez vous battez
album et ben vi en france pas été en
baisse après la toile elle m'a tuer
écrit un bouquin sont peu narrative
saida tôt et j'imagine
monsieur viendra se faire soigner en
france quand il sera ma mère j'ai
respecté pour hacher légitime je trouve
que michel polnareff est un ami très
proche
troisièmement de ma famille mon frère à
les connaître mais on dit que xavi tout
enfant donc celle polnareff n'est pas
exilé fiscal auquel il s'est fait
escroquer par un homme d'affaires il est
parti aux états unis non pas pour ne pas
payer s'adressait pas su japonais oui
mais pour les payer quand on vit dans un
pays on paye des impôts dans un pays
dans lequel on mais c'est normal puisque
ça sert à financer les services du pire
le cas ce n'est pas le sujet alors du
coup les gens qui vit qui sont allemands
qui vivent en france
ils payent les impôts en france on leur
reproche pas de balle et sa mégalomanie
mais pas du tout un problème la seule la
chose on dise que c'est opportuniste
mais pourquoi des artistes or un avis
différent des français les articles ils
sont pas sur un rocher spéciales etc à
une construction mentale nord d'accord
le seul et je vous donne la parole c'est
parce que dans les lianes humoriste
notamment dedans pardon je sais plus où
arnaud ducret pardon qu'il me donnait
aussi ça a choqué certains qui dit bah
moi j'en ai marre on nous prend tous je
pense que ce qu on lui prend à lui ça
lui laisse un pouvoir d'achat vie
d'avant les idiots chez ligier les
jaunes comme chez les autres c'est pas
dit qu'on était idiot alors attendez
opportuniste pour vous catherine
pourquoi c'est forcément peu à dire
peut-être un peu d'opportunisme d'abord
ils s'adressent alors alors alors public
mais en fait on a tous dans nos familles
quelques sans situation des gilets
jaunes on a tous des gens qui sont en
difficulté donc tout le monde c'est même
son envie pas personnellement mais tout
le monde est sensible à ça c'est normal
les artistes qui prennent la voie ce
normal pourquoi pas moi ce qui me frappe
c'est le silence assourdissant eux on
les a pas entendus c'est toutes les
grandes fortunes
tous ces grands patrons ils ne paient
pas leurs impôts en france
vous avez entendu devant une phrase de
compassion et c'est les people on le
voit dans les magazines tels aussi vous
avez entendu une phrase de compassion
comme une prise de parole à berne on
nous a dit que je me connaissent et il
est connu tout manqué son visage vous
avez entendu une prise de parole il
phrase de compassion une phrase qui dit
ah mais vous savez quoi
vous avez désormais plus vraiment sur
les people là aussi pour tenir sa très
opportuniste parce que c'est bon le dire
c'est bien beau c'est bien sympathique
mais je pense que les gilet jaune ce
qu'ils attendent de ce qui met la pole à
marmonner la jambe et là pour le coup
bas que dale farm moi personnellement je
suis gilet jaune que le mec
bisous soutien je suis avec vous et
éventuellement via même francis lalanne
se présenter aux européennes est accro à
ce propos et c'est pas du tout pour lui
mouiller la compresse comme on dit mais
ce matin cyril à 8h45 voilà sur un repas
on connaît ça veut dire qu'on arrête de
les dénigrer de l'est voilà ils ont
envie d'être soutenu j'ai maintenant là
aujourd'hui rachel c'est que quand on
est people je parle bonbons a vu
personne mais que je pourrai de sincères
trois secondes quand on dit rien on nous
tombe dessus et quand on dit quelque
chose on n'est pas sincère
pour ça il en remet alors du mépris de
classe où c'est ça daniel est à toi mon
show daniel oui c'est ça notre part je
disais syrie le cir est le mien ce matin
8h45 sur europe 1 s'il veut créer la
banque du coeur ou des grand grand grand
patron donnera de l'argent est ce que ça
se prête que ça se fera pas en tout cas
certains disent oui ignace et passionné
de faire ça en tout cas il essaie de
faire des choses au moins c'est vraiment
est justement franck dubosc était le
premier avait juste dire on vous aime
bon c'était très louable mais on sentait
qu'il avait envie de quelque chose et il
fait partie justement il ya mouloud
achour ya michael youn qui vont aider à
mettre en place cette banque du coeur et
donc je pense que c'est ça il ya eu une
prise de parole d'abord ça pouvait
paraître opportuniste pour certains là
il ya des choses concrètes et ce qui me
gêne un petit peu quand on les critique
ces people qui prennent la parole c'est
qu'on oppose un peu les nantis aux
pauvres pourquoi on peut avoir de
l'argent et je suis d'accord